Yes
,
thank you.
4 Suzuho's game is settled in about 5 seconds.
[Music]
So I'm preparing for 2 years
[Music] I
'm Takahiro Ito. I'm designing, manufacturing and assembling robots.
More and more smart makes robots fight each other I'm worried today
me
wh If it
depends, it's better
to push the opponent out instead of defeating the opponent
ran
[Applause]
[Music]
Robot  It's fun and fun to make, so I go here every day to
study robots. I spend about 360 days a year in this laboratory. The
most proud thing is to make all the parts myself.  It
means that
my robot is named Yagi 7 by processing it by hand.
[Music]
I wonder if the lot will move firmly after pressing the start button.  I
'm very excited because I'm in a position to be in a position of myself.
[Music]
It is thought that there are three points to win in the goal.
One is the speed to flick the opponent. The
last one is the defense power to prevent the opponent from sneaking in
.
I want to fight with
[Music]